well it's so it really dictates its own
language to talk to tied to try to
describe the infinite contradictions and
and ironies that are generated by
language language that's deliberately
perverse or often deliberately perverse
and simply for us because of its of its
nature of the unattempted tempt to link
life and language anyway without even
getting to you know a situation as as as
complex and fraught as war is a strange
thing anyway when you try you try to
hook up language with life you run into
millions of of shadows and and
contradictions and ironies I should say
that my experience of war in Vietnam was
quite limited oh but I did feel a
necessity to see what I could I mean I
wasn't in the military at that point I
was freelancing oh but you always
learned I think you learned from the
experience of war and I mind was not
circumstantially my experience was not
as demanding of me of I you know my
sanity is it as it was for many people
but I certainly I certainly found out
things that I hadn't known before when I
was in the military itself I really
hadn't seen I'd seen a lot of water I've
seen a lot of the of the world I
couldn't do much with it but like I
could see it I'd ever I wasn't involved
in any in any any action as a sailor
except as a witness to some of the
fighting in the Middle East but in
Vietnam I had I went to Vietnam with the
objective of being a witness
and you know this bit it puts you in a
place you haven't been so you know I I
learned a lot I think
no digit to put a lot of experiences
together and you know I wasn't there a
long time and I wasn't in the worst
places by any means but there's a phrase
in Lear that always took hold of me and
it's where Lear is wandering mad on the
heath and he sees oh the the character
oh it Edgar who is pretending to be mad
and who was pretending to be a beggar
and rags and and and in a way is now
beggar and rags in the play and leah
sees this demented youth who is coming
apart at the seams and chanting and
prattling and says on accommodated man
is no more than such a poor bear fort
creature as thou art and the phrase son
accommodated man always stayed with me
and I always associated it with what I'd
seen in in Vietnam and then what I'd
seen you know subsequently in in the
Gaza Strip in various places or
difficult places that I'd work on
accommodated man man in the wrong place
any then in the wrong place any person
in the wrong place on accommodated lost
threatened hungry dislocated on
accommodated and somehow those words
became for me a kind of prayer or chant
or his location or something so to roll
it all you know to roll them all
together you know what I saw the worst
thing I've seen I think has been the
spectacle of an accommodative man